we have a tweet from Elon Musk he says
why are they hiding these centers and of
course I highlight Elon Musk because
when someone with 170 or so million
people posts a video people take notice
and the Tweet here is actually uh uh
it's from a info unsensored I believe
that's what's watermarked in the video
this video is going so viral I don't
know what the original Source but this
is a man who goes into one of these
migrant facilities the Randall Island
illegal immigrant Center and he gets a
view into all of the tents I mean this
is a massive facility we heard that I
believe it's in Chicago the taxpayer is
spending $7,000 per illegal immigrant
per uh what is it per month and they're
bringing in thousands and they're
building these facilities you take a
look at some of this stuff it is
absolutely shocking here we go Henry
84,000 a year just so we understand
that's above median income in this
country fairly significantly actually um
I I want everyone to understand what
this means because the Biden
Administration is facilitating this
directly this means that when you you go
to work and you make $50,000 a year and
you're wondering why your gas is
expensive why your food is more
expensive and why you can't afford to
pay the
rent just just remember that the illegal
immigrant in Chicago is getting $84,000
a year in benefits that you are
contributing to through your tax
dollars that's crazy that's a lot of
money you get to pay for yourself your
kids their schooling their health care
as well as a few million uh illegal
immigrants who you know seemingly
because I know the rocket scientists and
the physicist they can't get into the
country but if you bring no skills and
you're going to be a dependent uh which
means you're going to be on the Democrat
Party doll and vote accordingly uh you
can come in uh with Reckless abandon
it's also incentivizing a lot of people
to come in that of course will be taken
instead of giving cuz if you created a
situation saying hey you guys could make
something out of yourself but you have
to work for it there's going to be
opportunities where you could prove
yourself that that's something else
completely different compared to we're
going to give you a bunch of free stuff
California you get a free sex change
californ you get free healthare and then
on top of this money that is given to um
these specific migrants we have to
understand there's also a larger
economic costs to housing the price of
housing is going to be going up as
there's going to be less available of it
the price of Labor is going to be going
down specifically with a lot of labor
now being available for a lot of workers
and it's going to get worse yeah well
the hedge funds are buying all the
housing they want you to be permanent
renters you know it's uh I I said it
earlier in a speech today here in Iowa
just if you had this sort of per
Manchurian Candidate and you were trying
to destroy America with from within what
would you do differently than today's
Democrat Party and the answer I can't I
literally cannot think of anything that
they they could get away with beyond
what they're actually getting away with
that could make it worse it's it's hard
to believe it's almost like if you were
trying to implement this plan to destroy
the country they got a pretty good one
oh it's a it's a phenomenal plan must
cost a lot of money it's doing great our
enemies are laughing their asses off you
know China's uh just loving what's going
on right now they couldn't have
orchestrated it better themselves let me
pull this article because it's going to
get worse New York Post Elon Musk warns
migrants are quote coming for your homes
after New York City kids forced out of
the classroom now the corporate press
doing what they do best I loved how they
did this to your dad Don Elon Musk
reports he comments on what's already
been reported they call him a liar I saw
this happen with uh during the Trump
Administration so many times to your dad
he comes out and he goes oh now they're
saying they're going to do X Y and Z
media then reports Donald Trump lies
about X Y and Z and it's like no no no
no no no I reported on exactly what Don
said what Trump said two weeks ago Elon
Musk there was a report in Massachusetts
I believe it was and in New York that
they were suggesting that private
residents give up space in their homes
to illegal immigrants the lieutenant
governor of Massachusetts and that's the
New York Post owned by Fox News That's
conservative programming you know let's
you know air quote it but conservative
programming actually taking that
approach that tells you everything you
need to know about our corporate media
even on the conservative side they they
want to put Elon Musk warns in the
headline they could have said Elon Musk
highlights comments from lieutenant
governor they could have pointed out but
I'm not going to I'm not going to roast
the New York Post for simply saying Elon
said it fine he did but the issue is
that now you got the corporate press
claiming that Elon Musk is lying or or
exaggerating in these claims when all
Elon did was read the New York Times and
then tweet here's my here's a here's a
thing I read well they did the same
thing to him about the Dei in like the
airplane thing it's like oh he's he's
racist he's like no I just want good
Pilots like you're doing programs that
are choosing people that are not the
best pilots and it's not an unreasonable
s to say I would just like a competent
pilot I don't care if they're green blue
purple it makes no difference to me I
just like them to be able to fly a plane
but that's not what they're trying to
push he retweeted James Lindsay who was
highlighting the diversity initiatives
and the bonus structure it's not just
like we want to try and hire more people
it was like you'll get paid more if you
hire non-whites and so Elon said they're
they're sacrificing would you he said
would you want to fly in an airline that
is sacrificing uh uh the skill and or
sacrificing safety for diversity and
then the media attacked him claiming I
love this NBC said Elon must claim this
without evidence and I'm like what do
you mean it's their policy he literally
retweeted James Lindsay's it's it's a
document from the airline breaking down
their diversity initiative yeah it's
a I feel like I wake up a lot of times
like right now and I'm just waiting for
like Ashton Kutcher to like jump out of
a cake and be like I we're you're just
being punked like no I feel like I'm the
star of The Truman Show at times like
there's no way this is real right
there's TV cameras following me around
in every room that I'm in because they
must be because no rational person uh
could do these things and yet and yet
it's happening I feel like that too and
it's like I think it's our bias is Free
Speech bias we've got this bias that the
American Constitution is preeminent and
will always stand but I think the most
of the world just wants it gone they
want us to live like like digital surfs
and not I don't know most of the world I
think it's the but but the people who
are in charge because the people that
actually hold that power you know the
world economic Forum guys like they're
never going to you know you can't drive
your car but I'll take my G6 you know
which will burn more fuel in 30 minutes
of air travel than you will in your
entire lifetime but no it's different
for me because I'm doing good and I'm
smarter than you and I know more so you
eat bugs I'll eat steak you you rent
your home from me forever and the second
we control the entire rental market
will'll jack up the rent and you'll be
surfed for Life yeah that's exactly true
it's not most of the world most of the
world wants free speech and they would
they would rise up against their
tyrannical governments if they thought
that they could win but it's these power
structures that are like trying to stomp
out free speech it's really insane look
I I I I said something rather uh intense
I'll call it last week when I when I'm
watching these videos of Law Enforcement
Officers facilitating crimes against our
country on the southern border
particularly let's go back in time a
month or so I we heard Texas said we're
going to make it illegal to to cross our
borders without you know through the
proper process
the Biden Administration threatened them
I entertain the the the the the issue
what happens when Texas state law
enforcement confronts federal law
enforcement and federal law law
enforcement is explicitly breaking the
law first let's start with a simple
question if a police officer one day
decides to rob a bank do we have someone
go and arrest that police officer and of
course there's no question robbing a
bank what if he was told to rob the bank
by the chief of police yeah yeah it
still doesn't matter he's still went and
did it what we have now is the Biden
Administration instructing law
enforcement we saw the videos of the
bulldozers lifting up the razor wire
they are facilitating illegal activities
against this country violations of the
Constitution shout out to Josie who's
sitting in uh sitting over here article
4 section 4 they're supposed to protect
us from Invasion instead they're
facilitating it now we're entering this
this this now the Biden Administration
is suing Texas over this to try and
continue the facilitation of illegal
immigration what happens when a Texas
law enforcement officer says you sir I
don't know who you are I don't care who
you are you are breaking the law and you
are under arrest and that guy says I'm a
federal agent don't you don't you try it
well listen it's getting to be
interesting and i' I've sort of gone to
Great Lengths only because I see so many
of these guys you know FBI agents or
retired guy they come up to me and they
see what's going on whether it was to
our family or whether it's just in
general and they're like you know it's a
tarnish on our badge it's you know they
saw the maralago FBI raid and they're
like this is insane this is ridiculous
I'm like so I've always made sort of the
distinction between the bureaucrat at
the top that's just you know beholden to
the politics and frankly all leftists at
this point and the door kickers but
we're getting to the point where it's
like hey guys if you're just like well
I'm just doing my job I'm just doing my
job I'm just doing my job literally
every day someone's rights being
violated the Constitution being violated
the law being violent like when like
when do we stop saying like hey man like
maybe you don't get a pass forever of
just doing your job maybe more people
need to speak out you saw what happened
with the FBI whistleblowers calling out
you know the entrapment or the Gretch
Whitmer uh you know fake you know
kidnapping and you know I'm sure all the
stuff around January 6th you know the
insanity there oh we can't show the
video because there's too many of our
agents in the crowd it's like so they
were there but they didn't do anything
to stop it it's almost like they wanted
it to happen when do we say like hey you
no longer get the free pass right uh I
was just doing my job because eventually
it doesn't fly this and this is what I
said last week that the there there are
people driving buses okay there there's
a report that I've highlighted several
times from several years ago of two uh
military uh uh uh I they're enlisted I
guess criminally charged for trafficking
illegal aliens the federal it was a US
attorney in Texas saying these these
guys were transporting migrants for cash
okay now you've got these James O'Keefe
did this video he filmed this Bus full
of illegal immigrants and they're being
trafficked you've got these big Airlines
trafficking illegal immigrants I want to
see those people driving those buses in
handcuffs yeah I want to see a perw walk
I want to we we can don't have a country
where someone driving this bus
trafficking engaging in human
trafficking says my boss told me to do
it it'll be fine in this video with
James they swerve in and out of traffic
trying to get away from him they go into
off ramps and then back on the highway
and then they call the police to try and
get rid of them when they're in fact the
ones breaking the law so what I said and
I'll say it again is that I hope your
dad gets elected I hope Donald Trump
wins in 2024 and I hope we don't got to
be crazy and arrest literally every
single person
but if you are on camera if there is
evidence of you facilitating crimes
against this country and working with
coyotes for human trafficking purposes I
hope you are criminally charged and
arrested and I will do everything with
my with my power as some doe to
complaints on the internet to say this
to anyone of influence I I'll get i'll
get me too I'll say I'll be right there
with you and when they come to take us
to the Googs it won't be under our
Administration but the second the
Democrats take over because they've
shown they're willing to do that uh
it'll no but you're right we we we see
it happening every day it's it's across
the board you know they're throwing out
veterans from uh public housing to put
illegals there they're taking over
hotels paying the owners of the hotels
money but this is tax it's not like New
York's functioning well right it's been
it's sort of a disaster and now we're
going to spend hundreds of millions of
dollars doing it you saw the do you see
that article I think it was NBC or CBS
News Texas spent $100 million shipping
illegals out of the state what a bad use
of funds
well if they sent 100,000 immigrants out
of the state of Texas bust them all over
the country got them out of Texas that's
about 1,000 bucks a person how much
would it have cost Texas to keep them
there so I mean the the article is so
gaslighting it's like oh my God they
spent aund million I'm like that that
would have that could have been1 billion
in the next two years just keeping them
there like you know but they expect you
to not believe you know beyond the by
line or not to see through it where
they've been so it's so flagrant these
but I'm not going to I'm not going to
defend Texas Florida or some of these
other states I know we all laughed when
they shipped illegal immigrants like
Martha's Vineyard but when they take
illegal immigrants from the border the
Biden Administration facilitates this
and lets them in and then Texas pays
these companies to shipped around the
country that is part of the human
trafficking process technically
smuggling it's uh tra it could some of
this might be trafficking trafficking is
when the person doesn't want to be
shipped uh but if it's of their own
valtion and they want to be part of it
then they're being smuggled human
smuggling y so I I think there needs to
be I I do not accept that this is some
kind of broad brilliant play for Texas
to be like aha we'll take those illegal
immigrants and send them to other parts
of the country the problem while I I get
what you're saying at the same time I
think you know you see the people in
Chicago being like wait a minute This is
BS like this can't be happening it's
like well no no no you guys have been
yelling about being a sanctuary City and
everyone's supposed to be this but now
that you actually deal with it and when
you look at the problem in New York or
Chicago just based on numbers it's a
tiny fraction of what tech Texas Arizona
you know border states actually have to
deal with and all of a sudden now
they're waking up so you know you do
need sort of the shot across the bows
like hey if you want to be a sanctuary
City we've been very clear in Texas that
they're not going to be they don't want
to be uh and they've been dealing with
these problems for many decades frankly
it's much worse now but you know it's
really easy to be behind your high fence
in Hollywood and talk about how
wonderful it is those people aren't
taking anyone else in and when they show
up in their backyard all of a sudden
it's a problem which which I which is
why can respect it to a certain degree I
still think it's bad however that being
said that's why I'm saying the Biden
Administration is facilitating this and
when Texas tries to do something about
it the bid Administration goes after
them the only real course of action they
have seems to be this political play of
send them to the sanctuary cities and
force these people to recognize what
they have supported by voting for Joe
Biden and these Democrats and in fact
because of this it is a large
contributing factor to why I mean I got
to tell you it's wild to see these
videos out Chicago where you have people
in the black Comm saying they're voting
for Donald Trump I've met some of them
and you have the youth vote in there
were three polls I believe so far
showing 18 to 34 year olds leaning
Republican for Donald Trump and that to
me is shocking it is but I think when
people realize hey you're a young person
you can't afford rent you can't afford
work you're living paycheck to paycheck
your Future's been stolen from you all
of these great crises the covid
lockdowns all of these things you've
seen and then they tell you $84,000 a
year going to the pocket of that guy and
it's coming from your paycheck they're
going to say I'm going to vote for the
other guy yeah I mean we had a pretty
good under those time you know again I I
see it and you know I don't pretend to
be I'm the son of a billionaire from New
York and I you know I took my kids I had
them I took him to Alaska I just
remember this one cuz it stuck out
particular I took him to Alaska we were
just doing a fathers like fishing trip
and we came back and we're like the
Anchorage Airport and I got McDonald's
for myself uh a 14-year-old and an
11year old and it was like 39 bucks and
I was like oh my god dude if I'm feeling
sticker
shock uh you know what's happening to
the rest of the country you know I had a
you know a mortgage uh readjust cuz I
had to maintain something for my ex-wife
or whatever you know a mortgage readjust
that I wasn't paying attention for and
just the interest alone just from the
change in interest rate from you know a
5-year arm readjusting was like oh my
God you know if you took it
proportionately to like the average cost
of a home in America it it could be
debilitating you know relative to Med
median income like I want to I want to
ask you a question before I read the
next article I want to ask you
uh Donald Trump gets uh reelected
elected again in the end of this year
what's the first thing he does what's
the first thing he will do to alleviate
the problem of this massive illegal
immigration flooding this country you
you shut down the border to stop the
continued spread you get rid of the
incentives to you know listen they
they're literally incentivized to and
and by the way it's a human crisis that
most people can't even imagine I mean I
I'm a big Outdoors Man Hunter and stuff
like that I have friends all over South
Texas with ranches and stuff I mean
they're literally finding dead bodies
all over the place uh from I mean you
know that that desert is not an easy one
to cross and the coyotes aren't exactly
friendly people and they don't exactly
do the right thing I mean it it is a
crisis on a humanitarian scale that most
people you'll never hear the numbers
you'll never hear about it and imagine
what what's reported in America is going
to be very different than what doesn't
make it in the Thousand Miles it takes
to cross Mexico so you you shut that
down you get rid of the incentives you
do the things like remain in Mexico you
hold them accountable for some of these
things and then you do have to start the
deportation effort because these
millions like you got to do it and the
way to eat an elephant is one bite at a
time man you got to you got to start you
got to you got to go aggressive thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net